[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are going to be talking about the
human heart today we're gonna be talking
about this amazing organ inside of us
that helps keep us alive a major pillar
of the human body and sitting down with
us is cardiothoracic surgeon dr. Evan
Sheikh hello hey Alan thanks for having
me on thanks for coming on to our show
it's awesome for you know it's an honor
and I've been blessed to have met you
and be learning from you and just even
have you in in my life because it's so
important to know someone that knows
about the human heart and what's going
on inside of this machine well you're
very kind thank you for that but it's
been a pleasure and obviously the
feeling's mutual everything you're doing
here at simulation series and your
passion about education and bringing
knowledge to the masses is so wonderful
such a great mission such a great vision
I'm just glad I can be you know play a
little part in that
that process yeah I think we have a lot
of love for each other which is awesome
and so important in in relationships so
that's so great and let's let's do this
let's talk about this I mean you how
long have you been practicing and you're
now at Kaiser I am I'm at Kaiser San
Francisco I'm a practicing
cardiothoracic surgeon but really I
focus mainly on heart surgery diseases
that can be surgically corrected that
affect the heart I'm very lucky in that
I am passionate about heart surgery and
diseases of the heart and cardiovascular
physiology and I've been able to find
a place where I can practice focused on
those things and you I think what did
you tell me that there's like four
hearts per week or is it eight hearts
per week that you're well different well
there's you know different hospitals
have different volumes of pure heart
surgical procedures that they perform we
do about a thousand heart surgery
procedures a year and so there you can
do the math I mean that's three a day
well at least more than more than that
so you know it's about but you know for
for cases - five cases a day and you're
doing one of those well all the surgeons
have a have a caseload on on average
people are operating about four four
times a week for cases or cases a we
yeah they some are some somes
sometimes more sometimes less and the
human hearts usually plagued by heart
disease or some sort of an issue that
needs attention let's start showing
maybe some of our slides and keep
walking us through let's let's start
from let's start from the top so you
know after this one you showed us that
there you kind of give us a very next
next one Ronnie I talked about your you
can skip that you know you've got so
really what what do cardiothoracic
surgeons do and we use operative
techniques to treat organs in the chest
cavity so that's the heart the lungs the
airway the esophagus and again you know
while some surgeons have a more broad
practice they do everything oftentimes
you'll find a certain surgeons focus
either in thoracic surgery that's
diseases of the lungs airway the
esophagus
a lot of cancer operations done for
those organs you know and the the other
kind of big school of cardiothoracic
surgeons are the ones that focus on more
heart surgeries so diseases that involve
for example atherosclerosis where you
have to do bypass operations on the
heart replacing or repairing valves and
then working on the great vessels and
those are the big arteries that come out
of the heart and feed the brain and the
body so that's that's really what what a
heart surgeon does yeah so so esophagus
and lungs can usually be plagued by a
cancer then the heart's usually a
disease they're usually underlying
disease processes that result in
structural deterioration of the heart
and its components yep which then need a
structural solution in other words if
you imagine the arteries of the heart
are pipes carrying blood and the
arteries are getting clogged you either
need you know to go in there and open up
the artery with a stent or you need to
create a new conduit surgically yeah
and bypass that artery altogether so
that's a structural solution to a
structural problem and these are
temporary solutions a stent will last
you for it'll help you get through the
next couple of years but another piece
of the body who could fall apart at that
and then sure I mean most structural
interventions in medicine are things
that you're doing to treat a disease
that is far progressed the holy grail of
course would be to identify why that
perturbance happens yes and arrest that
early on in development or identify how
you could treat it I mean it'd be you
know in some ways it would be great if
you could just take a pill and not have
any more heart disease yeah and if we
can get to a point where we're
identifying the the slow degradation of
the body over time and we can
v-nand gray hair along the way okay so
well let's continue expanding we'll go
to the next one yeah we talked about the
two distinct focuses the heart and the
other structures so thoracic structures
are the soffits and the lungs well the
heart is a thoracic structure as well
but the way that the the way the
surgical field is kind of the lungs and
the esophagus are not cardiac structures
right right cardiac refers to just the
heart thoracic refers to everything in
the chest cavity yes
so then anything to do with ribs as well
mm-hmm and sternum yeah this so bony
issues involving the ribs are usually
handled by people who have more of a
thoracic focus yeah but again people who
are cardiothoracic have been trained in
both it's just that they may specialize
in one area or another okay cool so I
think the heart is an amazing organ you
know obviously it's captivated my
imagination from a very young age
hundred thousand beats per day yeah and
it's a organ that it's a very
interesting organ it's a pump it's a
biological pump basically in its most
basic format yeah however it's a very
complex pump it's a pump that can
regulate itself that can respond to
physiologic and psychologic stimuli and
it's a pump that has many components
that help it to function it has valves
to ensure that blood flows in the
appropriate direction it has blood
vessels that feed the cells of the pump
to keep it alive and to take away waste
of the cells as any organ would it has a
rigid skeleton around which all these
semi rigid cells have grown and created
the ultra structure of the heart
and on top of all of that it has its own
electrical yes intrinsic pacemaker with
relay stations and specialized fibers
that help coordinate electrical signals
so that it's an organized kind of
contraction of the heart that allows
blood to flow in a very smooth laminar
fashion to where it needs to go how do
we tap into the energy that powers the
heart that free energy that power is the
heart where do we get that energy so
that we can use it to power our homes
and our devices come on now
yeah well unfortunately the adage of
there's no such thing as a free lunch is
true mm-hmm it's a it's not true free
energy its energy that's generated as
most electrical impulses in the body are
generated you eat you know we're all
kind of solar-powered at the end of the
day we're all solar-powered because the
Sun is providing energy that is allowing
us to grow food and then we are then
taking that food in releasing the energy
that's stored in the food and using that
to basically create little batteries in
each cell by setting up differential in
ions across cell membranes and that
potential then is harnessed to create
electrical impulses which then go on to
you know generate various physiologic
processes in that body how the heart
actually biologically does the pumping
well the heart does the heart does the
pumping because it is created like any
other muscle in in the body in that it
has you know filaments that interact
with each other there are these
molecules known as actin and myosin
and there's a set of biochemical
reactions that happen that allow those
filaments to work with one another to
tighten and then another set of
reactions that happen to allow those
filaments to slide apart from one
another and relax
and those contraction cycles are
dependent on the availability of energy
stored in molecules with fancy names
that we could talk about for hours and
hours it makes me so grateful to
understand the heart better and as you
unpack it more I just become more
grateful for what is inside of me that
provides me his life yeah so that's a
wonderful sentiment yeah what are what
are some other ones that are very
important here so what so the heart
pumps about five liters a minute five
quarts of blood about a minute yeah
that's how much day on average the heart
is pumping out over really miles and
miles of blood vessels that are
compacted and shrunk down in your body
and feed all the organs that are within
you and this is the oxygenation cycle
well the well it's the it's it's a it's
a it's a closed system in some ways the
blood is but it your body interacts with
the world so yes if you're taking in
oxygen from the outside and the heart is
pumping blood so that it can get oxygen
and release co2 which is a byproduct of
metabolism which all the cells create in
your body and so we bring the oxygen
through the red blood cells to the parts
of the body and then the co2 is to
byproduct that comes out and then takes
the waste out from yes from the
metabolism process across the body and
so your heart actually if you look from
an evolutionary standpoint it's very
efficient it's pumping every time it
squeezes it's actually sending blood
in two separate parallel circuits not
serial but parallel and those two
parallel circuits are one circuit is
responsible for sending blood to the
lungs allowing the exchange of oxygen
and carbon dioxide to happen and that
blood then comes back and goes into the
other circuit which is sending the
oxygenated blood and co2 deprived blood
or cleanse blood to the rest of the body
we have a graphic for this one yeah we
know we can talk a little more about it
these are some just some neat fun facts
so people often say that an adult heart
is about the size of a fist it's kind of
about the size of a fist and a half this
and a half you know and in various
disease processes it can even the heart
can get really big but you probably have
about a fist and a half sized heart in
your chest
it doesn't really sit you know all the
way over in the left it sits in the
center and then kind of light slightly
goes over into the left yeah it leans
left yeah and it's important the heart
leans to the left and on average it the
your heart rate is somewhere between you
know sixty to a hundred a hundred
considered fast
so most people sit between 60 and 80 for
their heart beat and you have a the
heart itself has chambers there's
actually we already talked that they're
two parallel circuits but beyond that
there are the workhorses of the heart
the ventricles they are the ones that
pump the blood to either the lungs or
the or the body the left heart the left
ventricle pumps to the body the right
ventricle pumps to the lungs and then
these are the two largest chambers those
are the two larger chambers that are
kind of they make them they make up the
two bulk portion the bottom the bottom
there above yeah
it's hard to use terms like top and
bottom the heart because the heart is
kind of situated in an axis that's front
to back
but if you think about the way blood
enters the heart the first chamber say
so the aorta the large ventricles are
not always on top on the towards your
like neck are they no they're not no we
should look at a picture of you art
let's let some and we can talk a little
bit so here you have so so usually the
kinematic like this like the axis looks
like it's like this yeah at sitting in
the end the chest where this this is the
apex of the heart and that's kind of if
you looked on yourself and be sitting
right about here okay and and the oh so
it's angled so that so the axis of the
like the aorta is angled towards here
well the axis of the hardest like this
the aorta actually comes up and curves
this way all right and so that the
chamber of the heart that kind of faces
the world is actually the right
ventricle that's in the front okay and
the left ventricle sits more posteriorly
okay okay and the atrium right just like
an atrium of a house those are the
little chambers on top of each ventricle
that first received the blood and then
squeezed it into the ventricle that kind
of little extra squeeze Prime's that
ventricle gives it even a little more
oomph so it fills up like a spring and
then squeezes down and sends the blood
where it needs to go so on the right
side the body will take all the blood
that's deoxygenated and it'll come into
the right ventricle excuse me the right
atrium the right atrium will squeeze
that into the right ventricle the right
ventricles we squeeze that into the
lungs the oxygen carbon dioxide exchange
will happen okay and then the blood will
come back to the left atrium the left
atrium will squeeze and that will go
into the left ventricle and the left
ventricle will then squeeze that
oxygenated blood all the way into your
body and the cycle will continue and
this is a different set of veins
for each one of these two veins are
structures that bring blood back to the
heart
yeah and arteries are structures that
carry it away okay
veins bring the blood away that back to
the heart yes arteries bring oxygen to
and blood to the body
and arteries not necessarily the way to
think about it is heart centric veins
drain into the veins draining into the
heart and arteries lead away far away
from the heart okay right and these is
so two again these different veins and
arteries so they're made for a purpose
in the body correct yeah correct because
if you think about it now we're gonna
get a little a little deeper here here
if you think about it veins that are
coming from the lungs the pulmonary
veins are bringing oxygenated blood to
the heart
they're the only veins that you have a
right and pulmonary arteries or arteries
leading to the lungs are actually taking
deoxygenated blood from the right
ventricle and taking it to get artery so
it's not as simple as yeah yes which is
it oxygenated blood or deoxygenated but
the way to think about it is hearts are
eccentric right it's easy for me I love
the heart so it's gotta be a hard time
sure yeah the veins are vessels that
kind of bring things to the heart and
arteries are vessels that carry it away
yeah all right cool all right so lub-dub
what are this the heart sounds right the
love this is your lub dub this is yeah
this is the stethoscope when you put the
stuff yeah or you put your ear on
someone to test this before yeah which
you know love doesn't love the Arts
Centre's lub dub I I really love like in
my like past relationships that was one
of my like favorite things to Jeremy to
just you know just like just you know
sit still for a second and I would just
put my ear right on the heart and just
listen and it would just sound so
amazing to live
it is I got to gotta take our time to
just listen like that at heart that's so
beautiful
well you know still despite all the
modern advances in imaging and you know
diagnostic technologies we have someone
who really has spent the time and effort
and has gained the experience of
listening to a lot of normal hearts and
an aura of abnormal hearts yes can scan
listen to the heart and get a very good
approximation if not a pinpoint
diagnosis of what's going on that is
crazy if you've listened to millions of
hearts I'm sure that if we can train
machine learning algorithms to listen no
stethoscope data yeah then they can
predict without even us needing to it's
already happened he's already talked
about that kind of machine learning and
identification of heart sounds is happen
it's people are doing that but you're
it's it's interesting because technology
is also playing a role there you know
before the best technology we had was
auditory auscultation right to be able
to discern for example if the loved of
which we still haven't talked about yeah
listen if i sell of drug so the lub-dub
is basically the sound of heart valves
closing okay and the reason those heart
valves are important is because i
mentioned there are these there are four
total chambers in the heart two for each
side blood has to go into the atrium
which receive the the blood then it gets
squeezed into the ventricles and the
ventricle squeezes them out into their
respective large arteries okay so if you
met if you if you imagine that you
realize that every time these structures
squeeze blood is either gonna reflux
back out of the structure unless there's
a valve to stop it uh-huh okay so the
valve the two valves stop it
four valve four valves because there's
on the ventricles and the atriums there
on the atrium and the ventricle to our
Theresa yes yes right so love is that
first sound that is created when the
heart big heart muscles squeeze
and the valves between the atrium and
the ventricles close those are the
tricuspid and mitral valves they close
AHA all right
so lub all right now the heart is
squeezing while those valves are closed
and the blood is being ejected into the
aorta and pulmonary artery so that so
the aortic valve and the pulmonary valve
are open and that blood is ejecting out
of those and as soon as all that blood
that it's going to be ejected is ejected
the ventricle relaxes and the aortic and
pulmonary valves closed that's a dump so
you get this lub dub a little of dub dub
low up to the right so if you hear nice
crisp heart sounds like that you know
that the valves are working well there's
no either narrowing of the valves or
leakiness of the valves let me see if I
can get this so then the blood flow will
rub into the atrium love is as those
valves are those while preventing blood
going reflux reflux e-town uh-huh and
then the blood is therefore first for a
split second for some time not split
second but for a few set for a second or
two as the heart is squeezing and
injecting the blood out of the aortic
and pulmonary valves and that's the dub
that's the dot one day close and then
and then and then it cycles the got
cycles again okay incredible it is
pretty impressive
Wow but right so what I was getting
evolution we would have you know just
and it would have never thought of this
if humans were left to like make their
own heart if we just had no idea what
was what a body was like if we were
robots and we had to make a biological
system we would have no idea how to make
a well what are they doing over a
trellis aren't they making their heart
in organs and kidneys and stuff come on
now if the humans could only work at
there yeah 3d printing is great it's one
so it's wonderful to be able to mimic
the work of an artist if that artist is
evolution so be it we can 3d print
something that's already been entered
into our consciousness but the quest to
create an artificial heart has been
ongoing since yes you know since the
really the inception of the
cardiopulmonary bypass machine
that's kind of the first big artificial
heart I think I saw an image of where
you were using one yeah and I will we'll
talk about that okay but even now I also
want to be sure that we have been enough
time to cover everything sure okay well
there's never enough time I don't I
don't know there's so many episodes by
the the artificial heart creating an
artificial heart has proved most
difficult because there is nothing as
good as the evolutionary product of the
lining of the heart and the blood
vessels to prevent blood from clotting
and all the artificial hearts that have
been introduced for human use are
plagued by this you can't create a
material that prevents blood from
clotting on its surface so you mean we
may have the energy technology soon
where we can miniaturize energy sources
and we don't have a drive line coming
out of somebody that they have a charge
we may be able to get parts that don't
have fatigue but one of the hardest
things is being able to coat the insides
of these artificial hearts so your blood
doesn't clot the slot in them uh-huh
interesting and maybe maybe the answer
you know will be some hybrid living
surface you know made of tissue
engineering on the inside of these of
these artificial hearts that remains to
be seen but it hasn't proven as easy as
one might have thought but it's a very
exciting field and it will help
longevity I
yes let's let's go on to the next one so
I just took one in for us yes
heart disease is very you know it's one
of the reasons I went into heart surgery
you know I've I lost my grandfather to
heart disease I never met him he was
very young and actually people who are
of South Asian extraction are have a
predilection to cardiovascular disease
and insulin resistance so a lot of this
runs in in my family it runs in many
people's families it's very common as
you can tell one in four deaths are
somehow tied into heart disease and it's
a big problem it's a big public health
issue
and it's very costly it's very it's very
there's a lot of suffering that comes
from this process with family and it
once even once we do get past heart
disease over time there will see some
other part of the biological system that
fails of course yeah okay let's go again
to the next one run a or DIC stenosis so
the point here was what is that heart
disease is a very broad umbrella so that
covers a lot of things that can happen
they can go wrong with a heart so before
I remember I was mentioning that the
heart is made up of muscle right it's
made up of arteries that feed that
muscle it's made up a vows that keep
blood flowing where they're supposed to
go and any one of those components can
go back be affected by disease processes
so when the heart muscle goes bad its
cardiomyopathy so the heart itself
doesn't this muscle doesn't squeeze as
well for example when the blood vessels
get affected that's atherosclerosis
that's what a lot of people associate
with heart disease like oh I have heart
disease I've got blocked arteries after
a thorough sclerosis and the other one
was my party in my op cardiomyopathy
which is a can't you can't lub dub is
easy well the heart itself the muscle
itself either can't squeeze or gets
really big and therefore can't relax to
fill so there's there are a variety of
things that can happen there and then
the valves themselves can go bad so
aortic stenosis is one of the aortic and
mitral valve are the most commonly
diseased valves of the heart then those
are on the atrium mitral valve is on the
between the left atrium and the left
ventricle and the or take valve is
between the left ventricle and the aorta
yeah okay okay okay interesting so on
the left yeah so Eric's nurses is very
common and it's you know part of this
five million
figure of a man five million Americans
each are afflicted with some kind of
valvular disease and about 1.5 million
people in the US suffer from aortic
stenosis that's premature restriction of
the aortic valve usually due to calcium
deposits and we don't know exactly why
it happens but it's very common and it's
a pretty severe disease when people
start developing symptoms about 50% of
them won't make it past two years so
that valve is gone you have to fix it
Wow
it just makes me very grateful for every
moment that I'm alive as well just
because I've we've had friends that have
passed that have been in their early 20s
and it's uh they can be quick blindside
family and yeah it's uh it's very crazy
you know yeah
very grateful for every moment alive
let's go to the next one Ron
coronary heart disease so this is the
atherosclerosis I was talking about you
know that almost is over 700,000 people
every year have what we call a heart
attack and that's in its most simplest
definition it's heart muscle that is
injured or dies because it doesn't get
enough blood flow and it doesn't get
enough oxygen and the heart is one of
those organs of the body
unlike the liver unlike this skin it
doesn't regenerate so once you lose
heart muscle for the most part it's not
going to come back it's gonna scar down
and then that eventual scarring over
time to the point where you have a heart
attack no the heart attack is the
initial insult that's where you don't
have enough oxygen delivery to these
muscle muscles or muscle cells and they
start to feel it so your muscles start
to get strained they start right down a
little bit and
and they may be on the verge we're like
gasping gasping gasping for auction you
know either they're not going to make it
in which case you've you know had an
infarction or death of the muscle or
oxygen comes back because somebody is
sent to them or they've gotten oxygen or
you've slowed their heart down you've
slowed the the metabolic demand of the
heart down and the little oxygen they
were getting is enough and they were
ischemic or not getting enough oxygen
for some brief period of time all right
let's do it let's go on to the next one
Ron Oh
so for some reason the yeah that's a
little off huh yeah thirteenth-century
should be underneath of the well I think
it's an animation actually but that's an
animation yeah but um the formatting
it's okay okay
we just we transferred it as a we
transferred all the files as a picture
oh I see yeah so anyway that I am I love
history I just find it very interesting
you know people figure these things out
over time and is this what the initial
model was that we thought this is what
this is William Harvey's depiction of
circulation from the 17th century my
goodness and his you know he was he is
credited with coming describing and
coming up with the scientific
explanation and the measurements
required to just to explain how there
are two parallel circular to the heart
goes one goes to the lungs and one goes
to the body but if you actually look in
antiquity of course this had been
described much earlier I think if you go
to the next slide there was an article
in the land Lancet in the 1970s which
you know described the lost works of
even the feasts who is a
a physician in the 13th century who
actually using the works of Galen was a
very famous anatomist in the 1st century
while looked at gaylen's works and read
his writings and figured out that you
know the blood wasn't just going from
the left side of the heart to the right
side of the heart but there were these
two parallel circuits and described you
know what we know today is modern
circulation which then william harvey
kind of rediscover years later all you
had to do is just carve people up after
they died yeah and start looking and
drawing yeah well somebody had to do it
he's good I was gonna say this
somebody's gotta do it
even even if in the feasts and his time
he wasn't really the social and cultural
environment was such that you couldn't
do dissections on cadavers so he had to
rely on on what Galen had done mm-hmm
and deduce things from that even the
feasts he owes me money I think I've
been to feasts Galen all right let's go
on Ron oh thank goodness for the initial
explorers just yeah well this is a whole
you know this was a whole historical
perspective on how modern cardiac
surgery actually came to be and one of
the one of the modern miracles which
allowed us to operate on the heart as
the creation of the cardiopulmonary
bypass machine and do we have a photo of
I don't have a picture of the Bible I
actually go to the next slide I don't
know if it's going to show up because of
the keep going one more here
one more no I don't think I have a
picture of the machine - blowing a
little bit more that's I thought I saw I
go back okay now this is just a
schematic of how I already pulled me
bypass works okay okay but I don't think
I have it sure we maybe at least show
this for now
sure oh yeah okay but I don't think that
the animation is working but basically
the cardiopulmonary bypass machine was
invented by dr. Gibbons who wanted to
find a way to stop the heart and operate
on the great vessels to remove blood
clots that could form and block blood
flow to the lungs at the time it was a
big problem because after surgery he
trying to stop the heart yeah any type
of after any type of surgery patients
became very prone to developing blood
clots and these blood clots could go and
cause life-threatening obstruction of
the vessels leading to the lungs so
there was no good way to stop the heart
open up the blood vessels take out these
clots and allow blood to flow freely and
dr. Gibbons was a young surgeon he was
working at the Massachusetts General
Hospital at the time and dr. Churchill
was the chief of surgery there and said
well I'm gonna give you some time and
some money and you some research
facilities and you're gonna go figure
this out yeah so he came up with the
first viable cardiopulmonary bypass
machine which was a machine that takes
over the functions of the heart and
lungs so that you can operate on them
and so this is an a couple valves it's
their pumps actually home pumps it's a
pump that passes the blood through an
oxygenator that oxygenates it and then
removes co2 from it and and also you
know warms it
and is able you're able to modulate all
the physiologic parameters of the blood
and control the pressure with which it
returns to the body so you basically
take over the function of the heart and
the lungs this is frequently used today
now it's a modern iteration of this
device yes without it yeah without it
heart surgery could not happen i way we
do it yeah right so the basic principle
is you put a tube into that right atrium
where or someplace to collect all the
blood around the heart you send it to
the cardiopulmonary bypass machine
yeah it then sends it back into the
aorta and then you can put a clamp on
the aorta and stop the heart and then
operate on the heart and do what you
need to do for a long couple minutes no
the heart can be stopped safely for now
up to up to I would say three to four
hours is kind of the upper limit of what
you want to stop the heart for you can
you can put a clip on that upper aorta
and you can stop the heart for its
nautical it's a clamp a clamp but you
stop it for a couple hours
yeah operate on it you have to you
basically and it's not love dubbing it's
no it's totally still and that's totally
still flash that's crazy yeah and then
and then the call the cardiopulmonary
bypass yes is acting as a circulator of
the blood so that it continues being
oxygenating yachty throughout that time
correct because are you you're still
breathing out Bri you not breathe you
are breathing or you're no no you're out
you're in it obviously the payout is
completely enesta size meaning you're
not even breathing though in your lungs
okay so then the so then so then how are
some of the oxygenation is happening
through the colon or Bart bass right
yeah okay and there's somebody this
emphasizes a team-based approach to
modern heart surgery you know you have a
specialized a person with a specialized
set of skills known as a perfusionist
running that Hardeep only that's right
that's the word for the perfusionist
it's the one that handles the blood
psych cyclic cyclical blood to here yes
and you have a cardiac anesthesiologist
as providing anesthesia yeah
you have specialized nurses in the
operating room that are assisting
getting the right equipment getting the
right sutures
you know making sure everything is
available to the surgeon that needs it
you have a surgeon and then you have
somebody usually assisting the surgeon
either another surgeon or a physician
assistant because so a surgeon surgeon
assistance that's our 15 minutes imma
let's make sure we get through as much
as we can now surgeon surgeon assistant
bunch of nurses a perfusionist
anesthetist assist so there's at like
six or eight people at least yeah Wow
per open body that's gonna happen yes
Wow okay this so this invention is major
pillar major pillar kardi
cardiopulmonary bypass machine was a
major leap forward and prior to this
people had done you know all sorts of
heroic things to try to operate on the
heart and achieve to some success but
the modern era of cardiac surgery was
possible because of the cardio Murray
bypass machine bless that and bless our
future innovations on top of it let's
see what else we can ya know if we can
do with it all right next one round
these pictures were blowing my mind when
I was when I was looking through this I
was like D this is the craziest Wow
so there's you that's me yeah so that
this is a this is an operation where
we're repairing somebody's mitral valve
and that's the valve between the left
atrium and the left ventricle and the
there therein in the modern era there
are different ways to approach the
mitral valve so this operation is
actually done not through the front of
the chest but through the side of the
chest or a small incision and let's move
one slide away was that back with two
slit right can you going to slides back
sorry go back to yeah this one right
here right so normally you enter in
through the sternum this is the
traditional approach to cardiac surgery
it gives the best exposure to the heart
and all the vessels yeah
and you use there's a saw that you
literally saw them use a saw Li's asada
divide the sternum gently and then
retract it so we have access to the
heart yes and then at the end then you
put it back together and you can put it
back together with wires or actually now
there's there's a zip tie you can use my
god to bring that bone together we can
just have a zipper and just unzip and
like play with it inside rongkhun
stronger and I zip back up okay all
right and now you were saying you were
you're coming in from the side those
other side oh yes so a mini and it's a
it's called a port access or a mini mini
incision it's a incision that's large
enough that allows us to see and
basically gives us a tunnel right into
the valve that we need to fix right into
the valve you need a fix yeah
let's go back to the photos again Ron
and then all right and then let's go to
the next one so this is a more
traditional approach this is somebody
who needed the aorta replaced as well as
the valve the aortic valve and that
entire section has been replaced from
beginning of the heart all the way up to
here
this is the head over here the feet are
down there that's the right ventricle
and left ventricle next to it this is
the right atrium and that's what you're
seeing there that ribbed looking
structure is actually a tube of what we
call Dacron which is very similar to
what you might find on on a sailboat and
the sail in fact that's the first a
orta's that were replaced was with
sailboat material dr. DeBakey was out
sailing and looked at
the sound said this is a good kind of
material that I could use to reconstruct
aortas and put it in the autoclave and
put it in a human body and it worked huh
obviously things have come along yeah
they can last longer that are robust
they last forever these things but
they're easier to work with they're more
compliant they bleed less I believe
Letterman yeah
next one Ron this is uh fixing a hole in
a heart oh my good
so on the left side you can see that's a
hole underneath the retractor there this
dart pictures don't come out so well but
you can see there's a there's a big hole
we already said it's right here it's
right here it's right there yeah right
there yeah and um and we basically just
so that hole up using a piece of
pericardium from a cow
that's been treated washi of flexible
biological material yes from a cow yeah
that's sewn into position it's Sonnen
and then Wow then that heals the hole
while when you have a hole in your heart
we must be feeling well you can have
many people walk around with small holes
but if you have you know if if you have
a hole that is causing a significant
amount of blood to go in the wrong
direction
then you obviously feel it let's go to
the next one run let's see here
oh this was an interesting case that
that image on the left in which you see
there is a bullet lodged in to the left
ventricles where where that metal piece
right there it's a bullet yes there's
anything that tiny Wow this was a young
waiter who's incredibly lucky that's
just a pad sponge to rotate the heart up
into our key this is a young man who is
very lucky he was shot and the bullet
lodged in the heart and we
we extracted it and repaired it Wow did
fine his life well the the system saved
his life rights he was lucky to get
emergency medical services there on time
though they did their job he got to the
hospital into the emergency room the
dachshund team did their job and then
got up to the operating room and we did
our job
damn that medical system holy cow we're
very lucky to live in a place where the
medical system you know we works you
know sometimes it doesn't but more often
than not it works and and we have very
we're very lucky in a lot of places in
the world somebody like this wouldn't
had a chance yes so Wow okay holy cow
yeah it's so true yeah let's see this
what's this oh this is a case where we
had to replace the entire first part of
the aorta so this is the feet of the
patient that's the head of the patient
here you can see that white Dacron
material so the aorta has been replaced
from where it exits the heart all the
way around to where it starts to turn
down and go into the chest downwards
towards the feet and the three you can
see these three little pipes coming out
here one two three and those pipes are
going to the blood vessels that feed
your arms and your your brain and your
face whoa whoa so that's the you know
innominate artery the carotid artery and
the subclavian artery on the left and
the issue was that this woman had a
large dilation of the aorta and aneurysm
that's a whole other subset of diseases
we have not talked about yet but these
are socratic understand of an aneurysm
is an abnormal die
relation of a blood vessel usually an
enlargement that's due to a weakening of
that blood vessel wall and the blood
vessel is follows the law of Laplace
basically which is once the blood vessel
starts to enlarge the wall tension on
that blood vessel increases in
proportion to the radius of the blood
vessel so at some point that vessel is
going to the wall tension is going to go
up to high and it'll rupture yeah and so
yeah that's why it's important to
identify these these problems and
intervene on them yeah oh this was just
more of a transition to I remember you
had wanted to talk a little bit about
the heart and its importance from a
cultural perspective yes teach us about
that well I you know I think even the
Egyptians were you know believed that
the heart was kind of the seat of the
human spirit and mind mm-hmm more so
than than the brain yeah and obviously
the connection between the heart pumping
blood and needed for survival was made
by earth by early humans and before we
understood how the brain works the heart
was thought to be you know the soul the
keeper of the soul
of the of the body and and if you you
know imagine you were an early human
just coming into cultural consciousness
and you kind of look that remains and
you saw you know this ribcage this very
elegantly designed protective cage and
inside you know that the human heart
sits there you would know immediately
that it is of great importance it's not
like a pinky toe that's out there
exposed to the world
potentially even the seat of the soul
and the brain is just perceiving the
environment and making these moving the
hand endings and gets a thing deeper and
not say the brain obviously a very well
covered with not just a well not just a
cage but a complete calcium encasing
known as the skull right yeah that's
accede protective protect they need to
be protected and the heart has the
ribcage yeah and then the sternum and
stuff but also the brain has the entire
nervous system erect and the heart has
the vascular system right yeah and many
people some people have postulated that
the reason many people are right-handed
is because of the position of the heart
in other words if you're defending
yourself against a lion or a predator or
another human your left hand is going to
be over here to prevent an entry into
the left chest part of the chest
yeah and then that means that you're
gonna your right hand right there you
what your oh interesting and so oh who
knows these questions yeah yeah who need
ever be a sport that is interesting
thought that is so interesting yeah I
don't fight fair anyway
five years later I it's so cool I really
hope we get answers to some of these
questions I want to ask you very couple
quick questions typically ask her guests
on the way out first question is do you
think we're alone in the cosmos no I
think the statistical probability of
some other type of intelligence existing
is is pretty reasonable and then do you
think we're in a simulation well let's
put it this way I have no evidence to
suggest otherwise
so it's possible do you think that
consciousness is localized in the body
when you speak of consciousness are you
talking about individual consciousness
certain
I would have to say I'm still too much a
man of science to say that it's not so I
would say yeah I think consciousness is
localized inside the body it's not to
say that it can't be transferred with
the appropriate technological means yes
so I am willing to concede that
consciousness can exist outside of the
body with the appropriate technological
platform but as of present
I think consciousness resides within the
within within our bodies and
specifically for you because I think
this is important to ask you what about
the percentage division between the
heart and the brain in terms of where is
the seat of consciousness more so oh I I
think it's completely in the brain oh
you think it's completely in the brain I
don't think consciousness exists there
is each organ system each cell has a has
a consciousness of its own not in a
sophisticated manner I think some
algorithms running out running
algorithms and running sophisticated
algorithms and perhaps even encoding
more than you know using DNA to encode
deep-seated generational memory there's
evidence to that effect but I think the
consciousness that we reflect as our own
that completely resides in our brain you
know and that's that's just based on my
scientific upbringing and background
there I have no I have no right and I
have no real ability to argue on it or
debate on a spiritual level because
that's not kind of an area which I feel
qualified but as far as the science is
concerned I think consciousness resides
firmly in the brain what are the the
what would you say is the future of
heart technologies so that's something
we haven't gotten into but I think you
know ironically a lot of the things that
we're talking about today from a heart
surgery standpoint I think will have
evolved into something completely
different and it's happening as we speak
a lot of the traditional surgical
techniques to correct structural heart
disease will be replaced by more and
more miniaturization and minimally
invasive techniques for example one of
the greatest advances that have happened
that has happened over the last few
years for treating a or tick valve
disease is the invention of an
implementation of Tavor which is
transcatheter aortic valve replacements
and that is instead of having to open up
the heart stop the heart cut out the old
valve and so in a new valve we are now
able to use catheters and introduce the
catheters into the blood vessels yeah
through the femoral artery through the
carotid artery Wow
through the axillary artery and put
those wires across the arctic valve and
basically shrink an aortic valve so that
you can then deliver it like a train on
a monorail you know into position and
deploy it without really even stopping
the heart
Wow so we can deliver through the artery
system we can deliver a valve about we
Wow and then and non-invasively
well invasively but way less invasively
correct that's crazy interesting and
then what else would would you say about
the future I think that the same will
happen for mitral valves that's
beginning to happen we're beginning to
make advances in that area and it's very
promising the way things are happening
for patients it's the world of medicine
these things are a bit siloed in other
words heart surgeons are mainly focused
on surgery and these techniques that I'm
now describing are performed by
cardiologists ah you're seeing a lot of
overlap of the two disciplines
and you're seeing a lot you know now
you're seeing people who kind of live in
both worlds yeah but I think the miners'
miniaturization will continue the
ability to perform what formerly were
surgical feats with catheters and wires
with minimal incisions and minimal
downtime will continue to be the norm
yeah and as far as coronary artery
disease goes I think we're getting to a
near limit of what we can do with stents
so I think the balance between heart
surgery for coronary artery disease and
stenting we're kind of settling out but
the big change that will happen there
will be on the medical front in other
words medicine front in other words
we'll be able to identify better what
causes the disease identify those people
early do interventions on a molecular
genetic level that prevents them from
getting the blockages in the first place
I'm really excited for that preventive
medicine whew sure ok very last question
is what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world wow that's
a doozy Allen you think
probably the ability of humans to have
compassion and love for one another
because that causes that truly in some
ways you see people act completely
illogical II sometimes and they act some
not in their in their best interest but
in someone else's best interest yeah and
yes there's there are certain displays
of altruism in the in the animal kingdom
but in humans a true altruism I think
does exist
you know selfless compassionate love for
others and I think that is one of the
most beautiful things that exists it
seems to be one of the highest callings
yeah of the spirit yeah wow what an
amazing show yeah well everything thank
you very much so much for coming on
tours
oh it's been a pleasure and honor I hope
I hope it's not the last time not at all
this is so interesting there's so much
to continue understanding about the
human heart
absolutely and about how this amazing
how it helps us stay alive and how it
has evolved with us over time and all of
its nuance that you helped unpack today
and how you help people in with their
lives help save their lives and that's
that's amazing work so we greatly
appreciate you teaching about us and
about the future of it as well
so thank you again of course thanks
everyone for coming onto the show if you
guys had a good time go and share with
two other people go and start teaching
more people about the human heart and
what you learn today maybe go make a
video about it go write about it
yourself don't just consume the content
go create comment below with your
thoughts subscribe join the family
during the community start chatting
amongst each other also join us on
patreon help us support this help us
grow it impact more people maybe we can
do a show around closer to the surgical
office sometime that would be crazy
that'd be super interesting to go and
highlight a lot of the interesting
medical equipment as well that's being
used today and bring that to you guys so
thanks for tuning and thanks for on our
producer-director much love everyone
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]